certainly I really regret we had to be
the bringers of this awful news we did
not know when we were elected that the
good times were about to end every other
school district and say to California is
dealing with the same thing Capistrano a
severely underfunded I mean if we won't
find the finger you point the finger at
Sacramento there's no doubt about it
we're going through some difficult
economic times right now but there's at
least one segment of the workforce
that's doing pretty well unionized
public employees while the private
sector has lost millions of jobs since
the recession began the public sector
has seen a net gain in California a
state facing a twenty billion dollar
budget deficit tensions between teachers
unions and cash-strapped districts is
high in April 2010 things came to a head
in South Orange County when 2,200
teachers in the Capistrano Unified
School District went on strike after the
board imposed a 10% pay cut we're
willing to pony up but to make it a
drastic and huge permanent pay is asking
too much there's one sticking point
that's the big t word temporary these
tough times we definitely are willing to
take our share but we want
the temporary with the trigger meaning
that if they come if more money comes in
it automatically goes back to teachers
South Orange County communities like San
Clemente and Laguna Niguel are very
attractive to families who can afford to
live here the area has a wonderful
climate great surfing and sailing and
quality public schools it's not exactly
the kind of place where you'd expect to
have a teacher strike I always say I
live in Paradise we have a Creek near us
we have bike paths walking spaces I mean
there were so many things that we took
into consideration when moving here and
and I mean obviously I having a six year
old it was a school so it was a big deal
it was a big deal that had a really
strong public school system this is a
great school district we are the ninth
largest district in the state of
California number one in academic
performance for our size we are very
fortunate to have parents active parents
as partners and that's a big part of the
success of our students even though the
public schools are performing well Tom
Bell a law professor at Chapman
University chooses to send his children
to the Van Damme Academy a private
school in Aliso Viejo for myself I think
probably a lot of those teachers who
went on strike are great teachers and
their teachers I would want teaching my
kids I don't want them teaching my kids
in that system though because the
incentives are all messed up
I want really good teachers incentivized
to be the best they can be for my kids
and I just don't see that happening in
the local government schools one of the
reasons public school systems are paying
so much for their teachers is that the
system is top-heavy most school
districts have a policy of first hired
last fired if we didn't have the
seniority rule then then I guess the big
question is how do you how do you
objectively decide do you what do you
base it on how do you decide we don't
watch his first person to go and believe
me I'm not the one who could come up
with that answer political discord is
nothing new in Capistrano Unified a few
years ago parents began asking then
superintendent James Fleming and the
school board some hard questions about
how the school district was being run
including why the cash-strapped district
spent 52 million dollars to build a new
administration building the concern I
think repair instance was a parent led
concern that the schools and
selves were needing a lot of repair and
there are a lot of children and
portables that were leaky and moldy and
why are we spending the money on a
district office building when the money
should be used to improve our schools
and I think that really started the
whole thing the recall was five years in
the making two election cycles lots of
recall signatures it was a community
effort on a bryson is one of the reform
trustees elected to the board in 2006 so
I was asked to come in and be part of
what I call our cleanup crew when we
came here no one knew what the budget
was in this place no one could
understand it and after looking at it I
know why they couldn't understand it the
reform board which promised fiscal
accountability got off to a good start
when we first came on as trustees the
first group of recall we posted all of
our budgets in the black but then the
economy tanked which resulted in a state
budget crisis and severe cuts to the
California public school system
Capistrano Unified faces a 34 million
dollar budget deficit next year in June
of last year we reduced by imposition
over 10 percent all our administrators
but we only have a hundred and
sixty-nine administrators whereas we
have two thousand teachers and then we
have the CSEA and our Teamsters and
other unions I think we feel like we've
gone from the frying pan into the fire
as bad as the Fleming administration was
we kind of yearned for those happier
times on this board has gone beyond
disrespecting teachers what the school
board as I understand it is doing is
trying to save some costs they are
constrained thank goodness I prop 13
they can't come after we taxpayers for
as much money as they want so they have
to economize and those teacher salaries
are a huge hit to their budget I
completely understand why they would
look at that and look at it hard in fact
employee compensation in Capistrano
Unified it comes from more than 85% of
the district's budget most of that money
goes to the teachers we are the third
highest paying district in Orange County
at this time an average teacher in the
Capistrano Unified School District earns
eighty one thousand
a year the top end is 98 thousand and
that is without health benefits or
anything else I'm standing up for
students more than anything else because
how are you going to be able to retain
and recruit great teachers when you're
at the lower and the lowest in possibly
in Orange County on on the pay scale
it's just not going to happen I'm
willing to bet there's a long line of
folks who would be willing to get paid
on average eighty-one thousand a year
and have the summers off and have great
benefits and a lot of job security but
in this economy you could find a lot of
people like that as someone who is glad
that the person that I entrust with my
daughter 6 hours a day is someone who is
thought of as a professional who is paid
well and highly educated that means a
lot to me underline the tension between
the school board and the teachers is the
union's concern that the board supports
of charter schools and voucher programs
which the Union sees as a threat in fact
I think is very transparent what they're
trying to do which i think is destroy
public education in capistrano if we had
had more competition in education this
would not have happened it might have
happened in one school that school would
have gone out of business or to fix
things up you would not have had this
huge system-wide shutdown the problem is
with charter schools it's using public
money without the oversight that's
necessary I teach you know the teachers
have no rights they can be
indiscriminately fired
there's got to be a better way so the
people who are worried about attacks on
the government system well I'd say step
up to the plate and make it something
that's not so worthy of attacking we
tell our five-year-olds we stand up to
bullies and we feel like we need to do
that too and we need to teach them
children are watching after a three-day
strike the school board and the teachers
union came to terms but with no signs of
an economic turnaround in California the
prospects for the future are unclear at
best complicating matters is the fact
that union members are now backing a new
effort to recall two of the reform board
members in the hope of replacing them
with union supporters after this cut
takes effect they still have a huge
budget cap yeah they still have teachers
with pink slips they still can't
guarantee that class sizes aren't going
to go up after all is said and done and
so we still have a quagmire
we can't keep paying government workers
what we've been paying what they say
they're owed and maybe they are owed
under these contracts where their boss
has essentially handed over our money
pretty freely so that can't keep
happening it's not about just lowering
taxes and it's not about I won't vote
for any new taxes there's got to be a
way that we support our public
institutions and I don't care if it's
schools or roads or freeways or whatever
it is but we need to have some new
thinking here I want to leave a sound
financial structure behind that takes
care of the teachers the workers and the
children and in order to do that we have
to do what is difficult at this time but
the long view I'm extremely optimistic
for reason TV I'm Paul fine